- You know, I left
something in another room,
excuse me, everyone.
(video game chiming)
- Oh, he still has the sensors on.
- Oh, look.
- Is that him in his room?
- Yeah, you can see him, that's funny.
What is he doing?
Is he on his knees?
Did he drop to his knees?
- Oh, he's probably looking for-
- No, look, he's crying.
He's crying.
Oh, no.
- He's just shaking.
- He's shuddering.
Is he fetal?
Yeah, he curled up, look
at that, he's fetal.
- Hey, Craig, buddy,
you all right up there?
- [Craig] Yeah, Bob, I'm coming right out.
(upbeat music)
- Greetings, adventurers.
- [Group] Greetings.
- As you all can see here,
we have a new traveler in our ranks.
This is my cousin Tyrell
and he will be controlling
the player character-
- His name is Kanye, he's a giant, yo.
- Dear cousin, traditionally,
a giant is not assumed by a player
it is a chaotic evil.
- But I wanna be a giant, yo.
All big.
- Okay, fine.
Well, travelers, you are
joined on your adventure today
by a giant named Kanye.
Now when last we left you,
you were at the inn of the North Star
in the town of Isildur.
How do you begin your adventure?
- I wanna get some bitches.
Where the club at in Isildur, yo?
- Tyrell, this is highly unusual.
I think the guys probably
just wanna go on the quest
that we've already-
- Steven?
- Yes?
- I would like to join Kanye
the Giant on his quest.
- Seriously?
All right, the two of
you enter the tavern.
What do you say?
- Kanye the Giant orders Alize.
- "Hmm," says the barkeep.
"I know not of this foreign
beverage of which you speak,
"perhaps you'd enjoy an elven ale."
- No, we both want the Alize.
- Alize does not exist in this world.
- Kanye the Giant slaps that bitch.
- Oh!
- Kanye the Giant attempts
to slap the bartender.
Here, the bartender is half hobbit
and very nimble, so you're
going to have to roll
an 18 or above to hit.
20.
- Blip, slap that hobbit's (beep) off, yo.
- Okay, Gallan the Cleric,
would you care to restrain
Kanye the Giant before
the town guard is called?
- I grab money out of the register.
- But Gallan the Cleric is lawful good,
and this act of thievery
would dishonor his gods.
- Hey man, the only gods
is money and bitches, dude.
- I accept Kanye the Giant's gods
and yeah, I steal some of the money too.
- You too?
Okay, would you now like
to continue your quest
for the Lance of Caldaharr?
- Fellas, we came here for bitches,
where the bitches at?
- All right, you see a bevy
of well-endowed winches.
- Great.
I grab them bitches and
we all go in my SUV.
- Fine, Kanye the Giant, Odarbe the Dwarf,
and Gallan the Cleric climb into his SUV
with their bitches and
their ill-gotten gains.
- And our Alize.
Plus Kanye the Giant puts
his demo CD in the CD-
- No, he doesn't!
There are no CDs in this world.
You know what, do whatever you want.
- All right, I guess I'm
the dungeon master now.
The Eye of Odin opens up.
16 titties fall out.
- Yeah!
- Hoorah!
- So you can say as much as you want-
- But you can't say the
name of the celebrity
or any part of their name, got it?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, we got it.
- You are so gonna lose.
- Oh, you're going down.
- Why don't you start
the timer and be amazed?
- And go.
- Okay, this guy, E=MC squared.
- Albert Einstein.
- Yes, that is correct.
- Wait, easy, hello.
- That seems fair.
- Okay, this is the Terminator.
- Arnold Schwarzenegger!
- Yeah!
- Yeah, yeah!
- Okay, we got,
"Are you talking to me?"
- Robert DeNiro!
- [Men] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
- This person pretends to be straight,
but he's really gay.
- Me.
(timer clicking)
- He is (clears throat) excuse me,
he's "Livin' La Vida Loca."
(timer clicking)
- Okay.
- He's a Latin pop star.
- I'm not a Latin pop star.
- No, you're not, it's not you.
He bangs, he bangs.
- Oh, Ricky Martin.
- That is correct.
- I wrote that one too.
(timer chimes)
- Man, Tyrell about to come
out here right here right now.
Watch this.
- What's up, ladies?
- Watch this, watch this.
Yo, Tyrell.
- Yo, what up, Lawrence?
- Hey, man, you wanna play
front hand, back hand.
- I don't know that game, man.
- It's easy, dog.
All you gotta do is say
front hand or back hand.
- All right, front hand.
(Lawrence groans)
(group laughing)
- Bam, I got you, sucka! (laughs)
- Oh, okay, okay.
I see how it is now.
- Come on, man, come on, you
know that (beep) was funny.
- Back hand.
- Huh?
- It's still my move, right?
I choose back hand this time.
- Really?
- Back hand, (beep)!
(group exclaiming)
- Goddamn!
- Look, Ty, I'm sorry, but I ain't sorry,
you know what I mean?
I mean, you asked for it.
I mean, you literally asked for it.
- Front hand!
- What, no.
Why do you want to get hit?
- I got it!
I figured it out, front hand.
No, back hand, back hand!
- No, look, look, dude,
hey, if you want me to
slap you across the face,
back hand, I'll do it, okay?
Don't think I won't do it,
but you know that I'm
(beep) with you, right?
I mean, there ain't no game
called front hand, back hand.
- Oh!
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I get it, I get it.
All right, all right, all right.
As soon as I get good at
front hand, back hand,
you wanna stop playing.
- Play what, man?
I made it up, so I could
smack you in the face.
- I'm about to smack you in the face
as soon as it's my turn!
Back hand!
- There ain't no turns (beep),
'cause it ain't no game.
- You ain't got no
game, (beep), back hand!
(Tyrell exclaims)
(garbage rumbling)
(Tyrell sniffs)
Front hand.
- Look, I don't know if you (beep) with me
at this point or what,
but I don't wanna smack a (beep) no more.
- Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha,
ha, where you going then?
Okay, forfeit, forfeit, (beep), I win.
I win front hand, back hand, okay.
Me and you.
(beep) me and you.
Hmm, back hand.
(Tyrell exclaims)
- Go, look at that.
- What, that's amazing.
- He's so good at this.
- Amazing.
- I know, look at your points.
(group cheering)
Look at that, nice, nice.
(group applauding)
- Dude, you have absolutely
mastered this game.
- Since Sheila left, I'm
spending a lot of time
playing the game.
- You're doing really good.
- Thank you.
- That's why we're here, man,
to help you get over her,
and check out this
awesome new game you have.
- You know, I left
something in another room,
excuse me, everyone.
(video game chiming)
- Oh, he still has the sensors on.
- Oh, look.
- Is that him in his room?
- Yeah, you can see him, that's funny.
What is he doing?
Is he on his knees?
Did he drop to his knees?
- Oh, he's probably looking for-
- No, look, he's crying.
He's crying.
Oh, no.
- He's just shaking.
- No, he's shuddering.
Is he fetal?
Yeah, he curled up, look
at that, he's fetal.
- Hey, Craig, buddy,
you all right up there?
- [Craig] Yeah, Bob, I'm coming right out!
- Oh, here.
Hey, man, you all right?
- Yes, yeah, oh yeah, yeah,
it's just my sinuses are acting up.
Yeah, you know, I was just
thinking about Sheila,
and you know what, I am totally over her.
- Awesome.
- Hey, let's get this party started.
- Sure.
Oh.
I forgot to get rid of this
picture of Sheila, excuse me.
- Hey, maybe leave the
sensors so one of us can play.
(video game chiming)
- Oh, he's dancing.
He's dancing with the photo.
He's doing this a bunch, is he kissing it?
- Guys, we don't-
- [Red-Headed Woman] I
think he's kissing it.
- Know what, I'm gonna turn this off,
'cause we don't need to-
- Change it and you die.
He's undoing his buckle.
Look at this, his pants are coming off,
his pants are coming off.
Oh, god.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
- Okay, that's happening.
- Oh, no, no, no.
Is he...
He is totally on the bed.
- Yeah.
- He's totally flat on the bed.
- [Bob] Oh, maybe he's
shaking a can of hairspray.
- Oh, god.
- Gross.
- Oh, gross.
- We shouldn't be here.
Okay, you know-
- Is he reaching down for his foot?
That's his foot, isn't it?
Is that his foot?
- [Bob] And coming back, coming back.
- Ooh, I am sorry, everybody.
Would you like me to make some snacks?
- Wash your hands first?
(video game chimes)
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh, I want you ♪
♪ But I don't need you ♪